the complex welcoming external to
ministerial our discussion ds has
sido very productive and moses adopted a
final substantive document that approaches
the different will be the headquarters cooperation the dice
elections florida despar our future
cooperation as shrewd as a broad
class as to the
fading of the immediate tenemos  that completing the
negotiation if in the course of the look
of the association sto is happy with
this game is possible with mexico
marco source and meets in the final silk past
the tenemos who profess this
opportunity of historical im and soul the
rapid progress the degree con chile
we will follow compromise  dos with
the implementation of the peace process
in colombia the implementation
of the association agreement and central
america our political agreement ide
cooperacion with cuba has now male nape
the world needs a nation sony da
sport.es expressed which then amos
fully lo  effort of the forms of
the general secretary of the
reserves  rdavo in line your forces and
peace promotion initiative
followed it and to do so I sustainable
cooperation for the arroyo gas and
the impulse of trade free the taste
as the generation of major in
opportunity version of the
influential entry equally  orienting mass
media for dating and mitigation
also climate change but of the
promotion of the genre
the session as rosia where
respect is an important interchange
while the participating country and
above all the years of the condition the
rector continue finding point ago he
went there that  commodore region discounting these
male values in common we could have
hugely positive impact on th
global agenda